hey Kerry oh man really came in at that
time everything's so crazy right there's
a lot of true stuff a lot of fake stuff
you're the head of the video research
department here but so you got some
pictures you know all the answers I know
how to find the answers Kerry's got it
let's got it
[Music]
so the first thing that was circulating
after the inauguration is this image
where it looks like Obama is touching
milania's but he is touching her but
that's not Jefferson looks like it look
at you can tell photos don't lie well I
think we found that sometimes we do y
billion fake photos I mean I think
they're trying to like manipulate
people's ideas about Obama specifically
with this one with other ones that could
be really like to Tavor that is that's
what they want to make and everybody
believed you I feel like that I don't
know look at what the caption of this
that is what will feminists say about
yes I think they're going after feminism
I'm gonna say right now I'd say both
Obama's are getting a little friendly
that is a low back Michelle Obama isn't
actually touching her about though
that's the thing this is photoshopped
you can kind of see like his arm right
there it's not the best I could just be
an extra arm wow I got a lot of work
done I mean he might have a secret third
arm
unfortunately but we can actually
compare it to like the live video the
inauguration where it very clearly his
arm is way high and this isn't like a
few frames after he was grabbing that
but okay hey they're coming don't worry
don't baby oh yeah you're just you're
gonna be just and just a momentary that
was it
oh well attach that that hey we're here
yeah that was actually very sweet
yeah Obama's did they touch Donald the
same way oh I don't think there's a lot
of gravity there's a new picture he's
got a big ol butt
now that's but worth touching okay so
you didn't really touch her butt
nope too bad yep so that one's fake the
next thing is it's been going around the
Kelly and Conway did stand up in the 90s
she's hilarious I see her all the time
she's really perfected her act so she
started in 1998 everybody was talking
about how she like tried to do Santa but
the real thing is that she actually only
did it once as a part of like a DC
charity event but she still did do it
like we have the video this is where she
got her inspiration of how she could be
such a comedic icon such a big character
who's to say it does look like she's
wearing a feather boa in this that's
funny now that's how we wanna watch it
we shouldn't watch it we could be biased
right I already love her
you could question her why don't we get
some comedians in here you have them
review it hey Derek which and
everybody's wondering about my leg your
leg I'm like well everybody heard of
sending this comedy show they're like
great guys so we did the charity event
all right you clearly you're biased get
out of here any bias I can't appreciate
comedy do any of you like it you can
stay all right good getting you can
really you know I'll be honest with you
this is like right the first one is
about Obama touches the bullet right
second is about Kevin Conway doing
stand-up like what what is one thing
that's going on that maybe people aren't
freaking out about the know this is a
crazy thing that happened overnight last
night Trump fires the acting Attorney
General
after she ordered the Justice
Department's like not defend this travel
ban because she said it was
unconstitutional she's on Trump's team
she was good like I can't do this yeah
he's like you fly but weirdly enough
Jeff Sessions the person who is
currently about to be confirmed Congress
is the new Attorney General he kind of
told her to do exactly what she did he
literally told her to defy president's
orders of the views the president wants
to execute are unlawful so now we got
somebody else she's gone we got this guy
named Dana yeah Dana I think he's like
the violin of the general Dana glinted
does happen to be it probably ends like
he was just like a federal judge and
Virginia before this this is a huge
promotion so then we have sessions
coming in and then maybe he'll stay
maybe me well maybe we'll get him you'll
know by the time I watch his video
sessions is in power you'll know better
than we do it's true we're in the past
this is so upsetting right I just wanted
this video to be about Texan vets and a
comedians rise to fame that's all I
wanted I'm sorry I want all these videos
okay to only do that but I mean I can't
promise
that there's a lot of stuff going on
here Obama open invite you can touch my
butt Michelle - you can all step my butt
Milana you can touch my butt
I'm sure what happened quick open season
on I'm cubie any politician may touch my
butt I'm gonna put that out there right
now so there's never a controversy later
on you can use this as the facts saying
no a Keith in 2017 said any politician
could touch his butt I can't wait to use
those other source
oh I can't wait for it to be a source so
now that we've created a new source I
feel like we've done a real job here I'm
Keith I'm Carrie this is what is real
right that's what we call this I think
that right
[Music]